we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
you can call anytime you want i got a
great voicemail from a very nice older
lady she says she's an older lady she
wants me to know the older folks aren't
all wacky conspiracy theories spreading
trumpists she also praises
my occasional pronunciation of the
animal dog
take a listen to this
hi david this is anne darcy thank you
for recently gracing us with the correct
pronunciation of the word dog anyway i'm
calling to see if you can give a shout
out to or some validation to your older
listeners yes we are not all science
denying you smack watching trumpets as
portrayed in popular media
thank you for clearly presenting
facts and knowledge keep up the good
fight thank you
absolutely ms darcy is completely
correct we have listeners
that i know of progressive listeners
into their 90s
and um that's a fantastic thing when we
say statistically
the disinformation is coming from 65
plus or when we say statistically on
facebook it's older folks we share
just because we make a statistical
statement doesn't mean i would wrongly
think that of every one of our older
viewers uh no doubt about it and i
appreciate the clarification we have a
great bonus show for you today
what actually came from the un climate
summit what happened there we're going
to talk about it
we will talk about a bipartisan bill
that would force big tech to offer
algorithm-free
feeds and search results we used to have
this you used to be able to just see
your twitter feed in reverse
chronological order no algorithmic
elements at all
um we're going to talk about that and
then lastly
things are not looking good in germany
from the standpoint of covid
um
and this could be what's coming for the
united states i i know i know it's like
we're again we're doing it again
um it's not looking good in germany i'm
going to talk about that my brother
actually just landed in germany this
morning for work and um
let's just say he made sure to get his
third dose before going over there so
all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com you'll get instant access
and i look forward to you joining me
then